one of the saddest and most puzzling
phenomena of psychological life are the
incidents commonly known as breakdowns
in which people find themselves suddenly
unable to carry out their normal duties
and fall silent
take to bed
and cannot stop crying
it can look mysterious from the outside
but what is almost always happening is
an attempt to untie a lie that someone
else has surreptitiously knotted into
our lives
beneath the breakdown a long repressed
truth is trying to break through layers
of deception
a person is unable to function normally
because normality has grown riddled with
something incoherent mean and impossible
the breakdown is a logical bid for
health and truth masquerading as an
illness
what has made us ill tends to be a
variety of perverse injunctions
under which those we trusted may have
made us live
for example
i'm ostensibly asking you to succeed but
i won't love you if you do
or
you must fail in order that i can bear
my disappointments
or
you must feel terrible about yourself
to shore up my sense of worth
or
worry all the time so that i can be
carefree
or
you can never be happy
for it would make me too sad
we have probably been trying to make
sense of these paradoxical messages for
a long time
but now rightly so we can't take it
anymore
we are compelled to untangle the
perverse position we have been placed in
our illness acts as our conscience
it won't let up until we have figured
out the truth
it can't tell us the truth by itself
but it is urging us to make the effort
to find it out
the twitching paranoia or despair are
there to keep us honest the illnesses
contract with us is understand me and i
will leave you alone
ignore me and i will upset normality to
prevent you from deceiving yourself any
longer
illness is the midwife of truth
the fortunate ones among us manage to
decode the riddle
we begin to get a sense of who may have
aggressed us
and how odd and sad it is that they
should have done so not least because
they might be our parent or our spouse
we have fallen ill because we have been
victims of a cruelty which we needed the
cover of madness to be able to look at
we aren't really ill at all
we may be closer to sanity than we have
ever dared to be
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face is that of working out who we
really are this book is designed to help
us create a psychological portrait of
ourselves with the use of some unusual
oblique entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more